PAY A DEVASTATING PRICE.
>> Sean: CHARLES PAYNE.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
NOW TEXAS SENATOR TED CRUZ.
ON A MULTI-STATE BUS TOUR.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU ARE HOME IN
TEXAS.
HOME FOR ONCE?
>> I AM HOME TONIGHT.
BUT WE ARE RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE
OF A 17 STATE BUS TOUR.
WE STARTED IN TEXAS.
DID 4 STOPS IN TEXAS.
WENT TO NEW MEXICO AND ARIZONA
AND NEVADA AND UTAH AND KANSAS
AND MISSOURI.
NEXT, WE ARE HEADED TO OHIO AND
NORTH CAROLINA.
MARYLAND, VIRGINIA, TENNESSEE,
GEORGIA, FLORIDA, MICHIGAN AND
THEN BACK TO THE GREAT STATE OF
TEXAS.
>> Sean: WE WERE IN GEORGIA LAST
NIGHT AND IN PENNSYLVANIA
TOMORROW NIGHT.
WE WILL BE IN A STATE I CAN'T
ANNOUNCE YET ON MONDAY NIGHT.
THEN ANOTHER STATE I WILL BE IN
NEXT WEEK ALSO.
WE WILL BE OUT ON THE ROAD AS
WELL.
THE MID-TERMS ARE THAT
IMPORTANT.
THE SENATE IN PARTICULAR.
MARCO RUBIO IS UP IN THE POLLS
IN FLORIDA.
HERSCHEL WALKER.
TIM SCOTT.
NOT WORRIED ABOUT HIM.
TED IS RUNNING A GOOD CAMPAIGN.
DR. OZ HAS TO WIN IF THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE ANY SHOT AT
TAKING BACK THE SENATE.
WE HAVE RON JOHNSON JOINING US
LATER AND J.D. VANCE AND SCHMIDT
AND MASTERS AND TIFFANY SMILEY
IN WASHINGTON.
WHAT DO YOU SEE ON THE GROUND?
YOU KNOW ELECTIONS.
>> I THINK THERE ENORMOUS
ENERGY.
I THINK WE WILL RETAKE BOTH THE
HOUSE AND SENATE AND END UP WITH
A BIG MAJORITY IN THE RANGE OF
30 TO 50 SEATS WHEN IS HISTORIC.
ON THE ORDER OF WHAT WE SAW IN
2010.
THAT ELECTION IS COMING IN
NOVEMBER.
IN THE SENATE I THINK WE WILL
TAKE THE MAJORITY AND I THINK WE
COULD BE ANYWHERE BETWEEN 51 AND
57 SEATS.
I PREDICT RIGHT NOW 53 OR 54 IS
WHERE I THINK THE SENATE IS.
WHAT IS STRIKING, WHERE YOU ARE
GOING AND WHERE I AM GOING.
YOU KNOW WHO IS NOT DOING THAT?
JOE BIDEN IS NOBODY TO BE FOUND
IN GEORGIA, NEVADA OR ARIZONA OR
NEW HAMPSHIRE OR OHIO OR N NORTH
CAROLINA.
WHY?
BECAUSE NONE OF THE DEMOCRATS
RUNNING WANT TO BE ANYWHERE NEAR
HIM.
THEY ARE RUNNING AWAY FROM THE
FAILED AGENDA OF THE RADICAL
LEFT.
THAT SAYS SOMETHING WHEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS A MILL STONE AROUND THE NECK
OF THESE DEMOCRAT CANDIDATES.
THEY HAVE BEEN RUBBER STAMPED
FOR THE RADICAL LEFT AGENDA FOR
2 YEARS.
NOW FORCED TO FACE THE VOTERS.
>> Sean: I LIKE TO KEEP THINGS
SIMPLE.
NUMBER 1 THE ECONOMY.
AVERAGE FAMILY PAYING $7200 MORE
BECAUSE OF BIDEN INFLATION THAN
UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
DOUBLE THE PRICE OF GASOLINE
THAN UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
THAT HITS EVERY AMERICAN.
IT'S IMPACTING THE POOR AND
PEOPLE ON FIXED INCOMES.
WE HAVE WIDE OPEN BORDERS.
AMERICANS CAN SEE THE DISASTER
WHERE YOU LIVE IN TEXAS.
EVERY SMALL TOWN AND BIG CITY
DEALING WITH DEFUND AND NO BAIL
LAWS RESULTING IN RECORD MURDER
RATES AND VIOLENT CRIME.
AMERICANS ARE TIRED OF THIS WOKE
EDUCATION FORCED ON THEIR KIDS.
KEEP IT SIMPLE.
>> LOOK, THAT'S RIGHT.
THE TOP 3 ISSUES IN THE COUNTRY
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
POLLING ARE INFLATION AND GAS
PRICES, NUMBER 2, CRIME AND
NUMBER 3 ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
ALL 3 THE DEMOCRATIC FAR LEFT
AGENDA OF BIDEN/HARRIS AND
PELOSI AND SCHUMER IS A TRAIN
WRECK.
IF YOU LOOK AT PEOPLE ARE
HURTING.
THEIR LIVES ARE MORE DIFFICULT.
IF YOU ARE A YOUNG PERSON COMING
OUT OF SCHOOL.
THE COST OF RENT HAS GONE UP.
THE COST OF FOOD WENT UP.
YOU CAN'T MAKE ENDS MEET.
IT'S WORSE IF YOU ARE A YOUNG
PARENT AND TRYING TO PUT DIAPERS
ON YOUR KID AND GET BABY FORMULA
FOR YOUR KIDS.
THEN THERE ARE SENIORS.
IF YOU SPENT 40 YEARS SAVING,
YOU WERE RESPONSIBLE, YOU HAVE
A 401-K AND A RETIREMENT.
SUDDENLY THE DEMOCRATS GET IN
POWER AND IN 2 YEARS YOUR
RETIREMENT DROPS 30%.
YOU HAVE SENIORS WHO ARE LIVING
ON THAT.
THEY HAVE A LOT LESS RETIREMENT
SAVINGS.
THE COST OF EVERYTHING SKY
ROCKETED.
A LOT OF SENIORS WERE GETTING
READY TO RETIRE.
I READ A STORY THAT SAID FULLY
ONE-THIRD OF SENIORS WHO ARE
STILL WORKING HAVE DECIDED TO
DELAY THEIR RETIREMENT BECAUSE
NOW THEIR SAVINGS IS LESS.
THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT.
PEOPLE ARE HURTING.
>> Sean: 46% OF AMERICANS
CONSIDER THEMSELVES POOR RIGHT
NOW.
ON TOP OF EVERYTHING YOU SAID
ABOUT 401-KS AND RETIREMENT
PLANS, YOU ARE 100% RIGHT.
NEW HOME CONSTRUCTION CAME TO
A SCREECHING HALT.
SALE OF PREEXISTING HOMES IS
HALTING AS WELL.
HOME PRICES ARE PLUMMETING.
HOME PRICES ARE ON THE WAY DOWN.
THAT MEANS EQUITY IN YOUR HOME
AND IN YOUR RETIREMENT ACCOUNT
IT'S WIPED AWAY.
GOOD JOB JOE BIDEN.
>> EVEN WORSE, IF THE DEMOCRATS
GET ELECTED, EVERY ONE EVER
THESE GETS WORSE.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN IN MY LIFE 2
YEARS A GOVERNMENT DO THIS MUCH
DAMAGE TO THE COUNTRY.
I DON'T THINK I THOUGHT IT WAS
POSSIBLE THAT THEY WOULD DO THIS
MUCH DAMAGE.
THEY ARE ENGAGED IN BLATANT GAS
LIGHTING.
JOE BIDEN IS TWEETING OUT IF YOU
ELECT THE REPUBLICANS INFLATION
WILL GO HIGHER.
WHAT?
YOU HAVE THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SAYING NOBODY IS
CROSSING OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
NEVER MIND THE 4.4 MILLION
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE LYING.
>> Sean: WHEN JOE BIDEN SAID THE
ECONOMY IS STRONG AS HELL HE
TOLD THE TRUTH.
HE WAS DREAMING.
HE WAS TOO ENGAGED IN EATING ICE
CREAM.
>> LET THEM EAT CAKE.
THAT'S A MESSAGE THAT WO